[Musica]
allora spieghiamola questa cosa non è
una presa di posizione questo cappello
per quanto lo possa sembrare ma ero in
america quando sono andato alle 3 questa
quest'estate dentro un negozio di usato
perché in america si usano tantissimo
questi negozi di usato si chiama dress
for less dove trovi i vestiti dei poveri
e li compri a una sega tipo con 5
dollari ti porti via una camicia e roba
del genere ho trovato questo cappello a
3 dollari e 95 mio in media l'ho preso
mio perché lo fai perché ho detto
siccome è in america
no come i casini la guerra fredda un
bordello detto che squadre non è
originale cioè non l'hanno fatto questo
l'originale l'hanno trovato nella
cantina di un soldato americano anziano
ormai lavorarla mezzo alla sua roba
l'avrà preso l'avrà dato al negozio
dell'usato e l'ho preso io io ho un
cappello sovietico originale a caso
passa le persone come state bene spero
che abbiate passato una settimana non è
vero perché lunedì quindi oggi ragazzi
volevo fare un video gameplay ma
stasera volevo fare ancora una live di
due ore e mezza quindi oggi non faccio
un video gameplay volevo parlarvi di
cose importantissime per quello oggi ho
sacrificato il gameplay
era da un po che volevo fare questi
annunci ma è arrivato finalmente il
momento magari sottolinea non è quindi
necessario proprio tantissimo dicevo era
un po che volevo fare questi annunci
siamo finalmente arrivati al giorno
dov'è il mio canale subirà una semi
rivoluzione cosa intendo per semi
rivoluzione
intendo che il mio canale da quando
esiste sempre stato gameplay gameplay
gameplay gameplay tutti il gameplay
tranne il sabato dove c'è il blog e la
domenica c'era è più il grandissimo il
gioco che non conosce nessuno il mio più
grande cambiamento da quando ho iniziato
a fare video è stato togliere happy with
questo incredibile cambiamento però
parte questo il mio canale non è mai
realmente cambiato e non ho intenzione
di cambiare radicalmente perché a me
piace quello che faccio quindi prima ora
sempre un youtuber che fa gameplay però
voglio aggiungere e portare più qualità
sul canale come aveva annunciato un po
per andare incontro a a youtube
un po perché volevo fare questa roba da
un po di tempo ma non avevo mai avuto
sono pigro ok sono pigro non ho mai mai
voluto farlo sono pigro tantissimo ha
impiegato tre video per capire come
togliere il riquadro alla videocamera da
oggi il canale subirà una variazione
andremo a ridefinire tutti e dico tutti
i giorni della settimana perché ogni
singolo giorno della settimana uscirà un
qualcosa in particolare non saranno più
giorni a caso ok quindi a settimana e
composta da sette giorni sette giorni
sullo schermo è 7 contenuti che adesso
andrò a mostrarlo contenuto il numero
uno partiamo da che cosa è conosciuto il
mio canale per che cosa è conosciuto per
il gameplay
ok il gameplay rimarrà sul mio canale
quindi non preoccupatevi e ci saranno
dei giorni precisi per far uscire video
gameplay il gameplay usciranno in
mercoledì e la domenica sono due
gameplay normalissimi fini a se stessi
quindi non è una serie tipo tipo autras
che ha più episodi episodi un episodio 2
no e un gameplay singolo di un gioco che
però gioca a caso che provo
ok tutti gli altri cinque giorni sono un
po diversi partiamo dalla novità più
grande è il martedì
uscirà una nuova serie cosa intendo con
nuova serie intendo questo questa che
avete appena visto è l'intro di unboxing
fa vj che cos'è un box in fa vj unboxing
fa vj è una serie che stiamo registrando
e abbiamo già portato a casa diversi
episodi con una troupe di videomaker
quindi non lo sto facendo solo io quindi
c'è proprio del del budget dietro questa
cosa dove mi si porta in ogni episodio
un pacco ok tipo quelli tipo lo scarta
jolie parchi che facevo tempo fa ma li
scartava cose a caso molte cagate perché
me li inviavano i fan provare a volte
erano cavolate incredibili
invece questo unbox unboxing sono pieni
di roba fighissime che io non conosco
quindi ogni volta che io apro il pacco
non so cosa c'è dentro e ci saranno un
sacco di cose non vi posso sperare
niente ma ci saranno cose incredibili ve
lo assicuro c'è questo in video meritano
la vita quindi preparatevi per un box in
famiglia di sarah incredibile abbiamo
registrato già tipo sei sette episodi
anche special guest perché alcuni
episodi hanno le special guest non li
farò da solo sono spettacolari veramente
cioè non è un video normale è un video
veramente cazzuto è una serie nuova e
questa la serie che ci sarà
tutti i martedì a partire da dicembre
siamo soltanto a 3 contenuti settimanali
animati rai fuori altri due insieme
questo credo vi piacerà abbastanza il
lunedì e il giovedì serie cosa vuol dire
serie vuol dire non farò solo due game
play durante la settimana ne farò 4 la
serie è un gameplay però cosa si in cosa
si differenzia dal gameplay normale
semplicemente il lunedì e il giovedì
farò un gioco
di una serie ad esempio auto a servizio
di uno episodio 2 episodio 34 i giochi
che vanno ad episodi quindi vanno
seguiti gli episodi in episodio tipo
matt father ti sto mica spolverando la
serie della prossima settimana la prima
non lo so ma non è finita qui perché
sempre il lunedì è sempre il giovedì ci
sarà la sera tutte le sere una live di
due ore e mezza questo vuol dire che la
domenica visto che c'è il gameplay non
farò più live quindi non ci saranno mai
più live di cinque ore ma la live e di
cinque ore è stata suddivisa a metà
proprio così in due ore e mezza visto
che bravo con l'editing e sarà lunedì
sera live di due ore e mezza dalle 9
alle 11 e mezza più o meno o dalle nove
e mezzo a mezzanotte dipende come sono
messo di base dovrebbe essere dalle 9
alle 11 e mezza
ok e stessa cosa al giovedì quindi
giovedì avremo una serie più la live
serale tutti loro e tutti i giovedì
salvo diversa segnalazione perché magari
ci saranno i lunedì di giovedì dove
magari non sarò disponibile e recupero
un altro giorno quindi ma passiamo al
prossimo perché non è mica l'unica serie
unboxing fa vj che uscirà sul canale
diciamo che ho voluto fare le cose un pò
in grande visto che unboxing fa vj c'è
un sacco di lavoro dietro non mi bastava
allora via con la seconda serie che è
una bomba nel vero senso della parola
perché guardate la intro
[Musica]
allora mi è stato detto che non posso
assolutamente spoilerarvi di che cosa si
tratta voi pensate di averlo capito
dalla intro non l'avete capito anche
questa per farla ci stiamo mettendo un
sacco di tempo più di unboxing infatti
non uscirà a dicembre questa questa
uscirà gennaio febbraio sono ipotesi non
è detto che uscirà genera febbraio ma di
base dovrebbe uscire a gennaio febbraio
perché è molto molto elaborata già line
tra un casino pensate come farla farebbe
con la serie questa uscirà a tutti i
venerdì quindi venerdì uscirà
esperimenti incredibile si chiama così
la serie però non sapete di cosa parla
di preciso ma sarà una roba veramente
incredibile lo dice il nome tra l'altro
lunedì serie più live martedì unboxing
fa vigenti mercoledì un gameplay random
come quelli che faccio
i giovedì di continuo della serie più
live serale anche giovedì di due ore e
mezza dalle 9 alle 11 e mezza ve lo
ricordo il venerdì esperimento
incredibile la domenica gameplay random
e sabato ha deciso di inserire il buon
vecchio blog che è sempre stato una
colonna portante del mio canale quindi
non mi va di privarvi dei blog perché
sono molto importanti vi dico però che
rispetto ai blog passati i blog che
usciranno da ora in avanti saranno più
elaborati di prima e ve ne accorgerete
con quelli che stanno per uscire quindi
questa è la mia settimana questo è fa vj
tv da oggi in avanti
vi dico solo quando iniziano le cose lo
scrivo in descrizione e sarà sempre la
descrizione sarà sempre aggiornata
quindi in descrizione trovate sempre da
adesso in avanti troverete sempre il mio
palinsesto con le cose che escono questa
settimana sarà ancora tutto normale come
è sempre stato dalla prossima settimana
quindi da lunedì 19 uscirà il primo
episodio della prima serie e inizieranno
le live serali quindi il da lunedì 19 le
live saranno dalle 9 alle 11 e mezza
quindi questa domenica che arriva sarà
l'ultima domenica dove farò la live di 5
ore l'ultima domenica poi iniziano solo
le live serali dalle 9 alle 11 e mezza i
campi boe voluto fare questa cosa perché
ora come ora escono sette video la
settimana compresa la live però la live
di domenica sostituisce il video di
domenica mentre le live serali non
sostituiranno il video di giornata 15
voi avrete sette video registrati
montati con editing in più di bonus
avrete due live serali quindi in totale
i video saranno 9 la settimana non più 7
mentre adesso sono sette compresa la
live che toglie il video della domenica
7 video più due live più di così è
impossibile almeno per me per il lavoro
che ci sono i primi video è veramente il
massimo che riesco a dare per dare
qualità ad ogni singolo giorno e vi
assicuro che la qualità non è che non
sono solo aumenta tv dove aumentata per
la qualità perché veramente stiamo
registrando ste cose da tantissimo tempo
da ancora prima del bug youtube quindi
sono orgoglioso di presentarvele anche
il blog di sabato 24 sarà il blog tipo
nuovo di quelli che usciranno quindi già
dalla prossima settimana sarà blog nuovo
la domenica non ci sarà più la larga
quindi sarà gameplay random
stessa cosa per il mercoledì mentre per
quanto riguarda esperimenti incredibile
che la mia ultima serie quella inizierà
a febbraio gennaio quindi non la
prossima settimana mentre unboxing fa vj
visto che sta ancora in elaborazione
inizierà a inizio dicembre
spero di essere stato chiaro ragazzi
questo è meno palinsesto lo trovate in
descrizione di tutti i video
io oggi ho dovuto dedicare un video
questa cosa per farvi presente come fa
vj tv cambierà dalla settimana prossima
in avanti
cambiamenti che non vengono tutti
insieme ma pian piano tanto quasi tutti
insieme perché va bene
manca poco all'inizio di dicembre se non
vi è chiaro qualcosa trovate tutto in
descrizione noi ci rivediamo mi aspetto
come prossimo video domanico a 100
ragazzi se vi è piaciuto
lasciate un commento è un mi piace anche
a vari social che come il dottore
descrizione se non siete ancora i siti
iscrivetevi e si va avanti verso nuovi
orizzonti
non so se è uscito filosofico come
pensavo però vabbè bella ragazza
[Musica]